Uh, well, uh, over the weekend I was looking
at my mutual fund account to see how things
went in May. And it is very, very ugly. One
of the worst months other than October of
2018 and December of 2018, one of the worst
month ever for my mutual fund account.
And part of it was this precipitous market
decline that happened at the end of May because
of Donald Trump escalating the world trade
war again this time by announcing new tariffs
on Mexico, which are quite frankly absolutely
ridiculous. And I'm gonna explain to you exactly
why today, uh, the markets are realizing effectively
that Donald Trump really is this dumb. Donald
Trump really is this ignorant about basic
economics and trade and it is really getting
ugly out there in the economic sense. Donald
Trump, as you might know, and we've talked
about, started a trade war with China and
we've gotten nothing substantive out of it.
And it has been a disaster for American companies
and American taxpayers, American companies
and taxpayers. Not China have paid billions
in extra dollars as a result of Donald Trump's
tariffs on China, $5 trillion has disappeared
in value from the stock market. There is no
credible off ramp from these tariffs anytime
soon.
Meaning away for Trump to, to get us out of
them and just sort of deescalate and go back
to where we were before. And in the meantime,
China continues to simply make other arrangements.
China's making deals with Russia on energy.
China's doing more trade with other countries.
And what does Donald Trump decided to do?
He decides to start another trade war this
time with Mexico. Trump announcing obviously
on Twitter, where else is he going to do it?
Uh, that there will be a 5% tariff on Mexican
goods until illegal immigrants stop coming
to the US. And that 5% could escalate significantly.
Donald Trump tweeting quote on June 10th the
United States will impose a 5% tariff on all
goods coming into our country from Mexico.
Until such time as illegal migrants coming
through Mexico and into our country stop.
The tariff will gradually increase until the
illegal immigration problem is remedied, at
which time the tariffs will be details from
the White House to follow.
What Donald Trump is saying is that Americans
will be paying 5% more for Mexican goods,
and Trump later followed this up by saying
that the 5% becomes 10% quote, if the crisis
persists, and then there would be an additional
five percentage points each month for three
months, getting all the way up to potentially,
according to the president, a 25% tariff on
Mexican goods coming to the United States.
This is true real idiocy. You know, sometimes
I look, uh, a search hard for the right words
to use to describe economic policy or socio
cultural policy or political decisions. This
is just idiocy and it's actually getting so
stupid that even many Republicans are saying,
this is a bad idea. The horribly depraved,
disgusting Republican idealogue. Chuck Grassley
even has the sense to say that these Mexico
tariffs are a misuse of presidential authority,
but there's something truly mindblowing and,
and just dumb about this.
The point here is that Donald Trump wants
to hurt Mexico with this policy, right? Donald
Trump doesn't like what he sees as Mexican,
I guess indifference when it comes to undocumented
immigration from Mexico to the United States.
So he wants to hurt Mexico. Now, let's put
aside for a second that there's a net outflow
of immigration to Mexico, even accounting
for undocumented, that most of the people
that are coming in over the border, many of
the people are actually coming from countries
further south than Mexico. So really we should
be dealing with the economic situations in
those countries. If you actually want to reduce
the demand of those citizens to go through
Mexico and try to get into the United States,
put all of that stuff aside. Trump wants to
hurt Mexico with this policy. If Trump succeeds
in hurting Mexico with these new tariffs that
will make the Mexican economic situation worse,
which will create a demand for more Mexicans
to try to come to the United States legally
and illegally, which is what Donald Trump
is trying to stop.
These tariffs are completely counter productive.
We've gone from Mexico is definitely going
to pay for the wall to Mexico, was not paying
for the wall, and now there isn't even a wall
too. We are going to put tariffs on Avocados
and cars and all of this stuff that comes
from Mexico. We're going to make that more
expensive for Americans, while potentially
increasing the motivation that Mexicans will
have to come to the United States illegally.
I thought we were told that businessman, president,
genius Trump was going to bring us economic
prosperity. We were told that this is some
kind of complex four d chess that Donald Trump
is executing on trade, which many of his followers
during the campaign, who by the way know nothing
about trade. People who know nothing about
trade, fell, hook, line, and sinker for the
idea that Donald Trump knew how to fix it.
Uh, it's not happening. This is triggering
the possibility of a recession and that probability
keeps growing. A second Trump term could be
utterly devastating to the economy of this
type of completely uninformed tariff policy
continues. And the most important and stunning
thing about this is that both Donald Trump
and his followers and some people who aren't
his followers to be quite fair and full, uh,
don't understand that when you tariff China
or Mexico, they don't pay for it. The importing
companies and people in the United States
are the ones that pay for it. Now, I don't
want to ignore the sort of economic theory
behind the tariff. The, the idea is that even
though strictly speaking the tariff is paid
by the importing countries, companies and
individuals, if we bring Avocados from Mexico
to the u s and they have a 5% tariff, it's
the u s importer that pays the 5%, which they
pass along to the consumer.
So avocados end up costing 5% more. The economic
theory behind it is, if you, let's imagine
that American Avocados are 3% more expensive
than Mexican Avocados. If you put a 5% tariff
on the Mexican avocado, the idea would be
you will boost local business because you
now have the option of either Mexican avocados
with a 5% tariff on top or American Avocados,
which are only 3% more expensive. These are
imaginary numbers, so you would shift consumption
from the Mexican avocado to the American Avocado.
The problem is that we are starting to tariff
items that are not, uh, the, the, you can't
easily shift production in the way that would
be required for it to work in that way. When
we're talking about aluminum and steel from
China, which are building materials that are,
you don't just switch your supplier overnight.
Companies don't have that flexibility. They're
not nimble in that way.
When there is a certain demand for Avocados
that's based on the fact that we are getting
them from Mexico. You can't just put a 5%
tariff on Avocados and all of a sudden it's
all American avocados that everybody's buying
the supplies not there. It takes a while to
grow these things. Cars, it takes awhile.
If, if you're buying cars that are built in
Mexico and a tariff gets placed on them, uh,
you can't immediately shift a production in
order to account for that in a way that will
work the way Trump may be believes it would
work. So we're going to dig into that more
after the break. But once again, markets are
realizing Trump doesn't know what the hell
is going on with these terrorists. Let me
know what you think. I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show,